revenons tout d'abord la question qui
nous vient à l'esprit la c est ce que
c'est lié au changement climatique tout
ça c'est sûr que c'est quelque chose qui
est extrêmement difficile à dire les
inondations on en a à chaque printemps
c'est déjà extrêmement variables un peu
problème climatique ou leur existence
par contre on sait que la hausse des
températures
ça va perturber le cycle de l'eau à
plusieurs niveaux d'hier consortium de
recherche ou la noce que montrer qu'il
ya des augmentations de précipitations
en hiver et au printemps presque partout
sur le territoire a ajouté beaucoup de
pluie sur un sol gelé ou de la neige
compactée c'est sûr que ça change la
dynamique de l'eau dap à travers le
territoire et les températures plus
douces plus douce ça peut aussi agir sur
la dynamique de la glace changent et sa
résistance favoriser son détachement est
ce qui va mener éventuellement des
embâcles
donc au final les changements
climatiques font en sorte qu' on peut
plus vraiment s'appuyer sur les
statistiques des années précédentes où
les statistiques historiques pour savoir
un peu les risques d'une année à l'autre
et les spécialistes estiment que jusqu'à
4 à partir de maintenant jusqu'à 80% des
municipalités au québec qui pourrait
éventuellement être à risque de certains
épisodes d'inondations d'une année à
l'autre
mais pour ça c'est beaucoup de rythme
aucune municipalité le problème c'est un
essai pas qu'un problème canadiens et
des études qui montrent ici 2030 jusqu'à
40% des territoires urbains à travers le
monde vont être qu'elles vont
éventuellement se retrouver dans des
territoires inondables est ce que la
science est ce que les données qu'on
peut recueillir peuvent nous aider à se
protéger
c'est sûr que il le prend le point
principal c'est qu'on puisse changer
notre approche face aux risques que
c'est la chose qu'il faut qu'on fasse en
ce moment une fois que une inondation
est en cours tout ce qu'on peut faire
c'est aider la population mais ce que
plusieurs experts veulent c'est con
quand ça passe et de la gestion de crise
a vraiment une gestion de risque et pour
ça d'abord une faune meilleure
communication entre les différents
paliers les acteurs gouvernementaux les
spécialistes pour pas que vos propos que
le risque soit pris dans son ensemble et
pour y parvenir il ya les fonds de
recherche en les fonds de recherche du
québec qui ont lancé un qui ont lancé en
décembre dernier le réseau le réseau
inondations intersectorielle du québec
est le but de ces gens-là savoir m de
comprendre les causes et le
fonctionnement des inondations d'évaluer
leur impact sur la population
est ce ça va vraiment aider
la prise de décision et une meilleure
prévention donc on voit qu'on s'organise
de plus en plus pour faire face à ce
phénomène qui s'annonce grandissant
qu'est ce qu'on peut faire pour aider la
population à mieux connaître les risques
d'abord c'est d'abord ce qu'il faut
c'est une meilleure connaissance des
risques sur le terrain parce que dans
les dernières années les inondations
2017 2018 au nouveau brunswick
on s'est rendu compte qu'il ya beaucoup
de secteurs à travers le canada qui
avait pas de cartes de zones inondables
ou quand elle en avait l etat vieille de
ya plusieurs décennies
donc pour changer ça il va falloir
beaucoup de données il ya des chercheurs
des spécialistes qui sont entrés
vraiment de faire des relevés au niveau
du sol avec des leaders sur un radar qui
utilisent des lasers pour évaluer avec
précision la topographie du sol et ça va
permettre de mieux savoir exactement où
l'on va s'écouler avec le temps on est
aussi en train de faire la même chose
avec de l'est font des rivières les
fonds de lacs avec des radars pour voir
la vitesse de l'eau ou est ce qu'elle va
s'écouler ou est-ce que toute cette
dynamique hydrologique va aller et si on
combine tous avec des meilleurs modèles
les meilleurs algorithmes mais ça
pourrait permettre de faire passer des
avertissements d'inondations généralisée
a vraiment des avertissements quartier
par quartier ou est ce que l'on serait
exactement où l'on voit aller quelle
région évacués et quelles régions peu un
protégé et est ce que ce sont les
informations qui pourraient aider à une
éventuelle relocalisation ou de
reconstruction
c'est sûr que ça va aider au
réaménagement du territoire pendant
longtemps on a favorisé la croissance
l'étalement urbain sans vraiment
réfléchir aux conséquences
on ne construit dans des zones à risque
on a éliminé des milieux humides qui
changé la façon dont l'eau traverse les
zones habitées et l'homme et on se rend
compte que les autres mesures de
protection qu'on avait comme lady goo
les barrages ça peut plutôt empiré la
situation alors que la confiance si
l'eau s'accumule à certains endroits ça
peut rendre les choses pires alors qu'on
veut essayer d'aider en bloquant l'eau
alors que la conservation des milieux
humides
ça aide énormément les autres recrues
qui a empêché l'eau d'entrer dans les
territoires habités donc c'est sûr que
c'est pas des solutions spectaculaire
mais protéger les régions humides c'est
vraiment ce qui peut aider avec le temps
pour nous protéger des inondations très
intéressant merci renaud et d'avoir à
actualiser votre sujet ce matin compte
tenu de l'actuelle tenir si ça ça fait
plaisir